welcome to this video yeah this is a new
blitz game here on the ICC and you see
that it is still the 50 time control
probably you don't see it actually but
you recognize that there is no increment
implemented which is quite surprising
because I actually waited to record new
videos I waited till May first but then
the ICC management for some reason
decided not to implement the 5+1 time
control and now we're back to where we
always been the 50 so it seems not much
that I can do um there is really no
particularly great explanation for that
probably some people send mails that
they love 50 I don't know so um if you
have some particular opinion about that
you can just state it in the in the
comments so I have to again play without
an increment and play on Luke against
Luke against all I guess all the time so
at least you enjoy that ok let's see him
we have a king's indian here with a
somewhat strange set of hmm yeah that's
probably not the greatest line ever that
I come up here with yeah well I was
talking more about the town control all
right okay so let's see what happens
here it's not terribly bad what I what I
have here but it's a quite an unknown
uncommon set up okay probably here young
he's got some activity
but generally speaking I I like the
position because f5 is such a
substantial weakness so on light d1 III
okay you can play at five maybe I should
just get the bishop to see to this could
be could be a good setup
the big drawback of this g5 move that he
played is that this geez pawn on d5 is
not controlling the f5 square anymore so
any f5 push which is certainly on blacks
agenda any of those pushes will will
give me the foursquare yeah this is an
interesting move it might intend some
peace sacrifice here or maybe just wants
to go to g6 also possible yeah in fact
this is what happened well I don't mind
that if you place f5 now our capture and
plays a night only for this shouldn't be
bad at all but well okay if I take a
number of times here and play 90 for
them maybe it's night XG to so cautious
with that how interesting yeah now i can
play g3 actually g 393 Bishop e3 orbit
should be three immediately now i can
also do that 191 III actually hmm not
bad okay but I'd like to do that play g3
at the right moment no that's that's
rather surprising should i do that i am
not sure i can always play h3 ok player
played slowly here really don't see any
any greater continuation for blood f5 is
the only only break that is still has
and this will only consider a foursquare
to me i have all the time in the world
team
now d-1 III would be very nice this kind
of regrouping they also sg3 the right
moment g3 can also be quite quite good
opening up lights for me actually on the
king could be a could be an idea b3 was
mostly designed to keep the rook
flexible so that I'm not covering be to
all the time with the rook well maybe I
can use it only one or something
interesting it seems that he wants to
play g-form yeah I can play pawn to h3
that that's not really bad g3 looks
looks more looks more testing though
really dance I'm g3 takes takes nice cut
this check for instance but I have Queen
h2 yeah well I don't know I don't want
to open it this up maybe g3 is the
better move it's very likely actually
but this is just very safe and keeps
them all my advantages yeah what can go
to g3 that's not not so terrible really
yeah maybe yeah I don't know check
yeah bishop yeah bishop f2 I cannot play
that's a bit unfortunate because of g4 i
am not a good idea but he's taking lots
of time I can also try to regroup the
night and some other way all the time i
also have night be five which is
interesting but not so much to the point
mmm how do i do that night e 2 is
probably a bit too meek yeah i would
really may be here and not really right
yeah this one at bishop f2 maybe yeah
but the one was the one was the square
for the night actually okay i still keep
keep most of my most of my positive
features in the position together i
think i just threatened to take this I
really think I do and maybe if I take
twice he's got g4 that's possible okay
not relevant anymore okay wants to go to
F form I still like to get this
regrouping in yeah but time right on f4
is really really a nuisance is there
some way to get the night to e3 without
getting attacked all the time maybe like
that
check okay this it looks nice but is it
doing anything yeah I need to I need to
get something going I'm we should be
fire force maybe maybe good now hear
this also be should be five okay it
doesn't it doesn't really play it for
some reason oops I cannot take on edge
form
check black for Fitz online wow we both
got really low here and okay there's no
increment i don't it looked like like
that because he had some some lucky at
the end but yeah very a tough
maneuvering game around here if you look
this position there is very little in
terms of Pawn breaks available there is
basically only f5 and yeah the real the
real problem or the real important point
is when i played h3 the h3 move is sort
of limiting both sides options probably
i have something better i was thinking
about g3 really maybe this is the way to
go the bourne point is that he probably
needs to take on g3s a night move i can
just take here and I'm just better so he
probably needs to take here and now yeah
maybe knight Knight to h3 or to h5 yeah
yeah it is just better really I had the
suspicion that this is this is good for
me but but maybe he's got this Chang I
can go here but this looks weird hmm
probably g3 was what's the better moves
I'm not sure I mean around here there
are various ideas I can also maybe this
is in fact the real idea I was trying to
to get to a 5 all the time with the
night which is not terribly a bad idea
but instead of all that I also could
have played on the queenside maybe this
would have been better I mean around
here it's clear that if someone is
better it is white but simply because
he's got the the dead
shop on g7 and I have this g3 idea I
have still have some ideas on the
queenside but maybe I should have played
on the queenside more yeah at the end it
was a time decider yeah note note that
this is also a case where where an
increment would just it was an
interesting position I mean right here
and it could have continued to be an
interesting game but it was just ended
by the fact that he was seven seconds
slower it's awesome reason and yeah yeah
please sir give your opinion in them in
them in the comments about this this
decision that there will be no increment
in in auto pairing I really would have
liked to play that simply because it is
very very beneficial for the for the
commentary you just have the time to to
to to to get games to their somewhat
logical end and some games that are
simply stopped by by time will continue
and actually have some content you just
get the better chest content in my view
okay what whatever so I'm glad to hear
your comments and also from the game of
course thanks for watching